what's up babies it's episode 165 of
congratulations and I wasn't even
totally sure if it was episode 165 but
it is episode 165 because I looked after
I said it which is a very [ __ ] bad
thing to do as anybody in charge of
anything is saying something and then in
fact checking it later but that's what
we do it doesn't matter it doesn't
[ __ ] matter because I'm not a
politician I'm a goofy [ __ ] you
understand I'm a goofy [ __ ] and I and
I'm chillin and it's episode 165 and did
you think that we weren't gonna do it
because it's the EO TW it's the end of
the world did you think that did you
think it was [ __ ] wasn't I was gonna I
wasn't gonna hit to 165 because it's the
end of days and those days dude the
[ __ ] movie end of days with Arnold
Schwarzenegger me and my friend Brandon
when we were younger in high school the
movie came out and of days and and he
would always make me go end of days and
that's a quick bad story to start off
your [ __ ] quarantine day 8 I think
it's day 8 dude I don't know I don't
know man I thought it was gonna be way
more bored than I was and honestly I'm
not I'm not that bored everything's good
just been kind of doing a lot of squats
walking out so I walk outside for about
three minutes and then get go like this
and then walk back in you know what I
mean
it's about it it's about it it's about
[ __ ] it dude
thought about growing my beard out and
doing a quarantine beard and then I
realized I can't do that because I have
one of those [ __ ] masks if I need to
go out in public and the masks work less
if you have a [ __ ] beard because it
goes into the the particles the [ __ ]
kovat 19 particles go into they go
around the beard they [ __ ] go around
the beard and under the mask and slip in
there like a crook dude I'm tired of
this crook ass coronaviruses man but
where I gotta cut it I gotta cut it I
gotta shave it I got all your boys gotta
be a [ __ ] baby face I'm sorry dude
your boy may have to be a baby face
because they covet nineteen that's it it
affects us all you don't see it [ __ ] us
all you know even if you're not dying
from kovat you might have to be a baby
face but yeah things are pretty much
running pretty [ __ ] shittily you know
pretty [ __ ] shittily about this in in
the country and also all of the world
but you know I don't even know what to
say to this I would normally [ __ ]
start by doing what do you call it dates
but I don't I don't have any man I don't
have any think up for this podcast so I
could keep breaking in the [ __ ] bags
know diddly answer you know what I mean
mmm-hmm yeah dude and the merch and the
[ __ ] you know the merch no did Leonce
and the [ __ ] podcast no did Leonce
and then I also have another thing I'm
working on that's gonna [ __ ] provide
with no did Leonce but whatever dude
that's neither here nor there
everybody's [ __ ] losing money off
this [ __ ] I'm losing a lot of money
granted no dance yeah but losing money
man the Brinks truck are backing up
slower yes sure they're taking a little
bit longer to get to their destination
but it's okay you know what we're gonna
get through this [ __ ] we're gonna get
through this [ __ ] for one reason because
we have to I love how politicians are
like make no mistake we will get through
this it'll be hard but we will all
survive we will get through this and
it's like yeah we will get through this
but only the people that get through it
some people are gonna [ __ ] literally
die so what do you mean I always want to
fact-check those [ __ ] four you
see that British Prime Minister with the
[ __ ] hair that looks like Dumb and
Dumber but he went through a [ __ ] car
wash look like it looks like literally
literally the Prime Minister of [ __ ]
Britain looks like if Jeff Daniels in
Dumb and Dumber and if Jim Carrey in
Dumb and Dumber had a baby
that's why his hair would look like it's
a ball cut but it's still messy as [ __ ]
and he's like might no mistake we will
get through it and it's like yeah the
people who get through it we'll get
through it
what about the people who are face down
on respirators that are gonna hear
Souths color but also true unless
there's comedy and truth you know anyway
dude I don't know I [ __ ] tweet stuff
and everyone gets mad still so the world
still [ __ ] move in woo the move the
world's [ __ ] still going the world's
the Energizer Bunny dude it'll still go
and yeah some people still think it's a
hoax that's hilarious
your cousin's gonna die Kove in nineteen
man i say that [ __ ] i don't say
coronavirus I say Cove in nineteen
because my [ __ ] is smart my [ __ ] is
smart man you know the [ __ ] [ __ ] is
dire my I love how a man I tweeted so
many thing every time oh by the way the
Internet is poppin now just so you know
if you thought the internet was poppin
before the coronavirus they're covered
19 the Internet is poppin more now the
internet was poppin and now the Internet
is poppin even more and you know it's
great because you get to [ __ ] just
basically chill out and do things and
you you basically if you're healthy and
you're chillin with your family you get
to be a piece of [ __ ] and not really not
only do you have to get to not feel
about bad about it you get to be feeling
like you're actually saving the world
how about these couch potatoes that have
just been couch potatoes in practice and
now they're like it's a long time to
shine with a bunch of [ __ ] Cheetos
and Funyuns on their mouths like crumbs
and [ __ ] it's my turn to shine hey mom
from the basement it's about turn to
shine you told me to get a job well [ __ ]
you [ __ ] just Funyuns dripping off
their [ __ ] chin let's go to our did
it [ __ ] with it with a helmet on they
have like a Broncos football helmet for
some reason hey ma it's time to go to
our mobilize the groups let's just meet
on the couch
[Music]
are you sleeping it's three o'clock I
know sorry mama run to save the world
Derrick are you playing our app Call of
Duty again the other four the fourth um
just trying to do my part dance on the
[Applause]
[Music]
world what are you doing mom getting
ready for work how do you [ __ ] part of
the problem see your ass down but we
need money now in times like these bring
back Funyuns [ __ ] that's him Derrick in
the [ __ ] basement wearing a Denver
Broncos [ __ ] helmet I'm John Elway
[ __ ] I knew my day would come just some
[ __ ] I knew some guy who's just
almost [ __ ] too fat with a his shirt
a little bit above and he's got shorts
on and stains on his [ __ ] like
blue-gray shirt I knew my time would
come here we go start on [ __ ] call of
duty modern warfare here we go start I'm
saving the world I'm going off to work
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you're part of the
problem bring back finance [ __ ] Derek
what saving the world do it amazing I'm
gonna watch America's Got Talent videos
for 6 hours in a row because I got to
save the world what are you doing we're
going to work bye [ __ ] [ __ ]
shout-out to direct all the Derek's of
the world that have been just [ __ ]
saving practicing saving the [ __ ]
world
practicing saving the world and now
actually saving the world you are our
[ __ ] first line of defense how
amazing is that I've been going out
traveling the world trying to [ __ ]
bring comedy to people now I can't even
do it I don't know how it is to be on
[ __ ] on a couch just sitting down I
don't know how to do that and now I got
to do that and one hour a day I get up
and just [ __ ] do some squats and then
go fart outside for a little bit and run
into some [ __ ] neighbors I don't I
don't know and wouldn't know except for
it's the end of the world
I met two [ __ ] neighbors the other
day walking down the street and they're
like hey I'm Mike and I'm Mike
we're both Mike we just hang out I'm
like ah what the [ __ ] is going on
I sorta got him at two guys named Mike's
hanging out together same age I think I
says I'm Mike and his name is Mike too
we're just friends that's what he said
okay man anyway dude our first line of
defense are in their [ __ ] mom's
basements just [ __ ] a bunch of white
guys that were gonna be like in cells
but now after after the [ __ ] is done and
after everything goes down that went
down and we all come back as a society
and we all get through it
like we know we can like the
prime-minister [ __ ] said with the
with the with the breakdancing hair what
that just got done breakdancing hair
that's what the Prime Minister looks
like he looks like his hair looks like
he just got done breakdancing you look
like you just got done [ __ ] pub uh
buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh
buh buh buh buh pump it up and pump pump
pump it up we will get through it anyway
once we get through it dude those guys
are gonna be the guys who get the most
[ __ ] dude just the [ __ ] couch
potatoes wow you look horrible did you
save the world yeah Wow
ripped ass [ __ ] are gonna be
like hey darlin and they're gonna be
like you look fit have you been going to
the gym yes
that's ruining Society haha anyway dude
shoutout to the couch potatoes shout-out
to the couch potatoes um anyway you know
how it is
it's all [ __ ] good this is how we're
doing it Bryan Callen called me didn't
pick it up yes dude I would never pick
it up [ __ ] that why would I pick that up
Bryan Callen dude I went to he's got his
podcast where he definitely has him
Brendan Schaub
and also three other people in the room
while they record they're all getting
Korona it's all good it's fine
I love how Bryan at a restaurant
complaining at the mayor did a fifty
two-year-old on
sir Graham complaining to Garcetti
that's his name right [ __ ] Garcetti
will sasso was like grilling him on the
text chain he was like I can't nothing
more 52 year-old than complaining to the
mayor about an Instagram that's
hilarious
anyway do it first line of defense dude
but everyone's getting it everyone see
this is the thing last week I was like I
wonder who's gonna know somebody once
we're gonna start knowing people who
have coronavirus now I know people who
have the corona virus I know people
personally who have the corona virus I'm
not gonna say their names cuz I don't
know if they want me to say their names
but I know people personally who are in
the [ __ ] hospital because of the
corona virus and they're [ __ ] spry
and healthy dude we're not talking about
old people um yeah so it's it's it's
it's rough out there I do know people
and I'm just trying to stay hunkered
down in my house with my fam so we don't
get it and every you know what do you
call it delivery that comes to the house
they say you don't you're not likely to
get it from the mail I saw doctor
talking about it on CNN so you know it's
true
and I saw I saw but so he said you know
you can wash your hands and wash the
packages if you disinfect the packages
you don't have to but certainly you know
it's not gonna harm you if you do so
every package we get I just [ __ ] piss
on it and then open it up and then we
and then you know eat or whatever it is
anyway first line of defense dude [ __ ]
these couch potatoes I'm trying to get
some [ __ ] the world got getting back
to give world back then back into order
you know I I have to say I do like to
make fun of both sides I made fun of
Biden last week a bit and I make fun of
trauma here's the thing about making fun
of the [ __ ] truck everyone you know
gets mad at whoever you're making fun of
politically but and and the people when
I make fun of Biden you know sometimes
people on the Left the the way left they
tweet me most of the time it's the Trump
people though that that tweet me if I
make fun of Donald Trump but the thing
is I'm gonna make that fun of Donald
Trump more because he's
in the news every single day and he's
the active president so they look
whether you like [ __ ] Trump or not or
what he's doing to the country during
this coronavirus which is you know
whatever you [ __ ] feel uh you know I
make fun of it and then people just get
[ __ ] nuts dude I love her I called it
I this is how when he said it was that
when when Trump was saying something I
tweeted about how he was saying that it
was a hoax
the here's the other thing - I don't
give a [ __ ] what snopes.com [ __ ]
reports I don't give a [ __ ] about that
Snopes probably is right a lot of the
time okay but it's no nothing like that
is right all of the time okay so I said
I love how Trump said it was a hoax five
days ago or whatever and now he's like
saying how it's not or whatever it was
and people were like he actually didn't
you know that the Trump supporters were
like he actually didn't say it was a
hoax do your [ __ ] research and don't
be on a platform and giving false
information on my first of all if you're
coming to muwah
for information about any politics hey
dude run off a drawbridge into a moat
okay because I am a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
I've said that so much on this podcast
and that's that I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
they don't think I'm more of a more
about than everything is politics okay
now I know that you know I'm a comedian
and I you know I joke around a lot and
some of the things I do on Twitter are
not really jokes or just kind of
statements or whatever but still don't
take information from me and that's 100%
obvious guy but so I said oh it's a hoax
or whatever and and people are like oh
no it's up to not a hoax look at this
and everyone was setting the articles on
snopes.com oh he was saying that you
know it he wasn't saying that the
coronavirus was a hoax he was saying
that the Democrats are using this
look see this how much of an idiot I am
I kiddin remember but they were he was
the Democrats were using this to make
him look bad
the coronavirus to make him look bad and
that was the hoax and dude I heard him
say it 90 [ __ ] times because I played
it over and over again dude I don't I
don't care what you think
he definite also doesn't matter if he
said what they're doing is a hoax or if
the corner of ours is a hoax because it
it impacts what the [ __ ] the credit was
going to the country anyway dude he said
we've got 15 cases and it's gonna be too
soon just for no [ __ ] reason like
he's Doctor Strange like he's looking at
all the possibilities like he's that
meme of get Zach Galifianakis with all
the [ __ ] equations and now [ __ ]
50,000 people have it in America so go
ahead and argue over semantics and go
ahead and argue over [ __ ] that doesn't
matter to a [ __ ] touring comedian
about politics go ahead but the only one
who's a [ __ ] idiot about it it's not
me it's [ __ ] well no I mean I mean no
look I am an idiot about it but you're
joining this conversation being more of
a [ __ ] idiot about it you're taking
what I'm saying as [ __ ] truth and do
my platform is for comedy only
[ __ ] this is a silly goose time
only and if you're not in this cult I
don't give a [ __ ] and that's on you
oh I don't know who you are you're still
using bro if you don't know who I am
that's fine but why is it my fault that
you're a [ __ ] dork and not in the
knowledge bro if you I love that's the
thing that I forget the [ __ ] guy who
I talk [ __ ] with last week some [ __ ]
guy who pretending he wrote a book was
like uh yeah I don't know who you are I
didn't know you're a comedian okay fine
you're gonna that's not my fault bro I'm
everywhere that's your fault oh it's not
my fault you're not cool I'm the [ __ ]
bro come on
get on board get on this [ __ ] boat
bro let's go let's go get [ __ ] and
sucked I mean that [ __ ] in our
[ __ ] or whatever not me I know it
sounds like that sometimes when I say
get [ __ ] and sucked but I mean the
girls it's whatever bro if you're gay
you're gay get [ __ ] in the [ __ ] but
my point is on that but my point is
don't come to me for [ __ ] any of the
knowledge any of the knowledge don't
come to me for any of the knowledge
especially when I think I know
especially when I think I know nobody I
love how people are like oh yeah the
[ __ ] left is so whiny and [ __ ] and
they are dude but bro so is the right
the rights whiny and [ __ ] but tough
really speaking you know it's just
that's the only difference the left is
like you can't do that it hurts our
feelings and the right is like you can't
do that I'll shoot you it's the same
[ __ ] thing they're both big [ __ ]
so just [ __ ] on the [ __ ] couch you
know it's not a hoax and dude so what
man here's the other thing it's like
will the clue the flu kills the millions
of people well whatever dude just sit in
the couch for two weeks who [ __ ]
cares I get it some of you need to go to
work I get it I get it it's gonna be
[ __ ] hard but these are lives we're
talking about right you grandma might
dying and I also I'll [ __ ] go ahead
and say it I don't know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking about but what I do know is
the [ __ ] new Rams logo looks like
Trump's [ __ ] face and I it looks like
his profile and I said that on Twitter
and people are like acting like it's a
political statement when I'm not even
saying anything bad about him I don't
know I don't like talking politics man
on this podcast you come to this podcast
for a silly goose [ __ ] time I get it
but it's just what's been going on I've
been listening to [ __ ] CNN and Fox
News back and forth because I like to
get both of them you know and this is
what's going on with the [ __ ]
coronavirus is this the only thing
that's going on really I mean even the
[ __ ] stuff Harvey Weinstein has it
the coronavirus which is crazy
I mean if karma was ever not believed
then you'd believe
then I don't really believe in karma
though you know the only way I believe
in karma is it if you put positive
energy out there it's a good thing
because more positive energy in the
world makes a world more positive but
that's where it stops do it some people
are like whatever you do comes back to
you know dude go get [ __ ] that's
ridiculous man this is the world we're
not this is not movies there's no [ __ ]
bowtie ending where everything's all
[ __ ] make sense
this doesn't make [ __ ] sense oh you
got a practice good because if you
practice good then you get good nah not
necessarily man some people are so good
and get hit by a car and then get better
and then die a cancer like for real
legitimately happens so don't come at me
with that [ __ ] karma [ __ ] um but yeah
but if there ever was a case for karma
its Harvey Weinstein but everyone's
getting the [ __ ] coronavirus anyone
how the [ __ ] does he know by the way why
does he get a test I asked I asked why
someone why he gets a test and they say
well cuz he has money but he's in jail
don't you not have access to your funds
when you're in jail also no I don't
think there's another I don't think
there's an also I was just talking about
like don't you get I don't know man
that's crazy that he got it though it
looks like he had it [ __ ] four months
ago though it looks like he had it when
he came out with that Walker
he was probably pretending and then he
got and then God was like okay but are
you gonna pretend here's a little bit of
Corona and then he [ __ ] was like ah
now I really need the Walker
you know I guess karma is a [ __ ]
I was going to say that
the [ __ ] before I you know what
before I even it's a lot he's Corona
heavy I'm sorry guys but we're getting
through this together well I'm also I'm
not sorry because we got to talk about
what we got to talk about and we're all
in this together so but one time when I
was a kid I was doing it [ __ ] uh I
did a uh god I forgot about this until I
forget where I was I saw Ajax or
somebody mentioned Ajax somewhere bro
one time I was doing theater in
Community College white guy and I did it
and I was we were doing grease played
Kenickie white guy and I sang grease
lightning dude Oh white guy anyway um in
Glendale Armenian so anyway and I did
that and and there was a guy I can't
remember his name but he was a guy who
talked like this and he was like a
string bean dude the guy was one of
those guys that was so skinny that he
started to drip over you know what I'm
talking about like he was like one of
those flowers that looks tired he looked
like he was just going cool a lot brawl
I'm a [ __ ] writer I should be I
should write but the problem is I don't
know how to spell that [ __ ] GUI um
anyway he was [ __ ] we had makeup on
because we wear makeup in in theater
because that's how you do it dude was
the lights are gonna be you know you
don't want to look like a goddamn corpse
and I always look like a corpse anyway
and so uh and so this guy we were down
after doing the musical did I love
musicals man I [ __ ] love musicals
every musical I've ever been to the
opening act I cry and I'm not [ __ ]
lying I saw all of them every musical I
see [ __ ] tears down my cuz it's
beautiful a bunch of people singing
together that should his views of
beautiful if you don't think that's
beautiful put a vest with a bunch of
pockets on and go [ __ ] for a walk so
we were wash it we you know we can't
came down to take the makeup off and
this dude can't remember his name but he
came out that tall [ __ ] drink of
water that would look like a tired
flower came down and he was like where's
this soap and I was like dude I don't
know I think they got rid of it already
because they were packing up
then I turned to take off my [ __ ]
leather jacket and mom jeans because it
was greased lightning because it was
grease and then I hear the dude and we
would laugh at this to it a lot of
people would laugh laugh at him but like
I liked the guy a lot
I always liked [ __ ] weirdos man ever
since I was a kid I always liked weirdos
I liked like Russian kids and I don't
mean Russian kids are weird but they are
weird when you're coming when you're in
[ __ ] la cañada they're just like
they're the outsider
I like Russian kids I like [ __ ] kids
that were like where my mom couldn't be
friends with their mom like that was my
[ __ ] that was my go to anytime there was
a friend as anytime there was someone in
high school I could sense that their mom
couldn't be friend with my mom and I
would [ __ ] go for it my mom would be
like why can't you just hang out with
[ __ ] friends that have cool moms I
can't speak to this person they don't
even speak English and I'm like that's
why he's my friend bro anyway I'm taking
off my leather jacket and I hear oh and
I'm look over and it's the dude and he's
over that [ __ ] one of those
industrial sinks that all like the
basements that the theaters have and I
say what and he says I don't think this
is for your face and I look over and
he's got white powder all over his face
and he's using Ajax to wash them makeup
off and I'm like oh yeah that's Ajax and
he goes sit not for your face
I said yeah bro I'm sure he's fine but
that was a lesson for him and bro I
laugh I cried I cried I immediately
slapped so hard I started crying it was
one of those [ __ ] japanimation
crying's we're all the [ __ ] the tears
started [ __ ] going out the side of my
face anyway dude that's a little break
from the corona stuff but I'm gonna do
uh I'm gonna do ads now uh [ __ ] let
me get these ads up I don't have I don't
have my guys here because I'm doing it
by the way this is how [ __ ] I'm doing
it for you guys I didn't invite them
over because I'm quarantine I don't want
these [ __ ] over Ivan get rid of
and uh one fire dude they're not here
they're not here right now because if
they got that [ __ ] Rona I don't want
to get that and they both have beards so
you know that roan is [ __ ] chillin
how
a little bit of a party in their beards
so I don't want them to [ __ ] cuff on
my baby and [ __ ] so I'm doing this solo
and I'm still doing it for you because
because it's very important in times
like these for you guys to [ __ ] to
have entertainment and also I get money
but then that's mostly it that's mostly
what the thing is if you ain't even
doing this for the money mang what's
your [ __ ] purpose that's like
the two parks song one of the [ __ ] uh
what's-his-name's say it without loss
say alright dude
add keeps uh look my hairline it's
[ __ ] back further than it used to be
my hairline is back further my hairline
is back further than it used to be
sensational and that's not good
but what helps me keeps because
preventive measures is the thing that I
like to use so that's why I use keeps
and who knows if I'm really gonna go
bald but keeps us here to help because
it's a prevent prevent print preventive
measure
two out of three guys will experience
some form of male pattern baldness by
the time they're thirty five the good
news with today's advancements in
science keeps offers proven treatments
that can combat the symptoms of hair
loss and help you keep the hair that you
have at half the cost of your local
pharmacy did you know that dude you
don't have to go broke to avoid going
bald keep-keep offers generic versions
of the only two fda-approved hair loss
products out there some of you may have
tried them before but probably never for
this price prevention is key keeps
treatments really they work they're up
to 90 percent effective at reducing and
stopping further hair loss the sooner
you start using Keefe's the more hair
you'll save so act fast
get it now dude many men have even
experienced hair regrowth that keeps
with keeps treatments find out why keeps
has more five-star ratings and reviews
than any of its competitors and nearly
100,000 men trust keeps for their hair
loss prevention medication for a limited
time you can get your first month for
free wha
for free that's one hell of a deal
forgetting to keep your hair otherwise
you know you're gonna keep girls drier
than they say hair if you go bald if
you're ready to take action and prevent
hair loss co2 keeps calm / congrats to
receive your first month of free of
treatment for free that's key that's ke
pS calm / Congrats blue aprons saving my
ass during this pandemic dude I still
get deliveries and they rip options are
everything especially when it comes to
food and especially now man I don't know
what you have in your fridge during this
pandemic but dude maybe not much maybe
got a can of tuna and some mayonnaise
and that's it and some hot sauce that
your aunt gave you but with more weekly
recipes than ever blue apron makes it
easy to eat well they offer a wide
variety of recipes that fit your
lifestyle for health-conscious options -
new blue apron premium meals that
feature exceptional sensational
ingredients and advanced techniques
create a plan that works for you with
blue aprons ever-changing mix of premium
putting out forward vegetarian
carb-conscious mediterranean diabetes
friendly approved and and 500 calories
or less options choose from a variety of
chef design ready to cook meals prices
start at you probably like well what our
prices start as the forty thousand
dollars no check this out prices
starting as low as seven point four nine
seven dollars and forty nine cents per
say per serving that's crazy it's
flexible blue apron you got a busy week
skip skip weeks cancel anytime we can
you probably none busy now but anyway
it's good man it's really good meals
that are coming up hibachi style steak
and shrimp with snow peas mouth is
watering bok choy and marinated
cucumbers chicken Amman dude I've had
all these great things from blue apron
recently they keep it fresh and cool
cooking doesn't have to be a hassle blue
apron gives you options and makes it
easy taking the guesswork out of dinner
so you can enjoy a home-cooked meal for
more information visit blue apron comm
that's blue apron comm blue apron feed
your soul anyway and I loved this dude
this was my some of my favorite let me
see if I can get it of course I already
axed out of it I love an axe out of
stuff even though I shouldn't [ __ ]
axe out of stuff here we go but this was
great dude actually let me play this
this is hilarious that Marvel did this
I love Marvel [ __ ] but dude once peoples
here's the thing I don't like here's
what I don't like is the twin when they
way
they have an agenda anytime I can sniff
an agenda in anything I'm out dude woo
I'm out man I'm out that [ __ ] if
I'm gonna go skydiving if I'm gonna go
watch people skydiving and I'm just
along for the ride in the plane and I'm
just chillin and I don't have a pack on
and I'm like well I would never jump out
of a plane I just wanted to make sure
that you guys were all safe and was here
to document it and then they go like
this okay cool and start talking like
there's an agenda I say give me the pack
I'm out and I jump out dude I [ __ ]
hate agendas I don't like them that's
why whenever you sniff something like
it's look it's fine dude I get it you
want to have all the equal opportunity
[ __ ] and all the [ __ ] and like
you know you should have all the
different kind of colors and every
[ __ ] show is fine looking like a
McDonald's commercial I get it put a guy
in a wheelchair in it that's fine but
the second you put too many guys in a
wheelchair in a [ __ ] show or the
second I sniff that a guy was cast
because he wasn't white the second I get
that bro I'm turning on something else
just because I don't want to sniff the
agenda make it [ __ ] real this is the
best of that right here this tweet is
from Lilith Lovett the first non-binary
superhero in Marvel and they named them
snowflake no this is not fake and then
this is the thing I lost no flake and
safeSpace are there's two ones named
snowflake and one's named safeSpace
first of all let me just tell you right
now that's worse than Batman and Captain
America that's worse than cool names
because those names are for [ __ ] who
wants someone to [ __ ] save your life
you want you want [ __ ] uh Marvel
what's the [ __ ] girl who didn't like
when she was going through TSA cuz the
guy [ __ ] Forester a guy to hit on her
what's her name Marvel head what's her
[ __ ] name brie Larson what what the
[ __ ] did she play Captain Marvel
Marvel head I don't give a [ __ ] whatever
she played that name is cooler then
[ __ ] hey help help
don't worry [ __ ] safe spaces here no
no no no no I want the Human Torch he's
got fire look at this [ __ ] ass [ __ ]
also two white guys created this
snowflake and safeSpace are the twins
and their names are very similar to
screen time it's this idea that these
are terms that get thrown around on the
internet yeah no [ __ ] we've heard them
that they don't see as derogatory I mean
okay there's no superhero with with the
n-word you know what I mean there's no
superhero with any racial slur for a
reason
so let's not take anything derogatory
and make it a positive cuz a gun get in
trouble that's just [ __ ] right for
the pickin
that's a farmer going trouble it's so
easy don't do that now look take those
words and kind of wear them as badges of
honor look this guy doesn't even believe
it you know he's just like I don't know
I got [ __ ] 40 grand for making this
[ __ ] they told me to make him
[ __ ] androgynous and I may be brown
so I just did it look it's a white guy
just like I'm getting in trouble for
this probably aren't I getting in
trouble
safe space dude trying is I love it you
can get in so much trouble for trying to
help serve honor safe space is kind of a
big burly sort of stereotypical jock he
can create forcefield okay it's but he
can only trigger them if he's protecting
somebody else okay I get it
Affleck is non-binary snowflake is
non-binary and she went further
snowflake is non-binary he doesn't have
a [ __ ] or a [ __ ] she he she he or she
he is not she I don't know whether to
call her he or she because he or she
doesn't exist there is no [ __ ] or [ __ ]
on him or her
the bone structure is androgynous you
can tell snowflake has the power to
generates individual crystallized
snowflake shaped shuriken 'he's the
connotation right you know color cold
[ __ ] or some [ __ ]
snowflake do it I would love it in the
first issue they just [ __ ] got just
mowed down with guns you know the word
snowflake in her and then they've just
[ __ ] driveway ago Trump nation
what's your name snowflake force field
[ __ ] say space right now are
something fragile and this is a
character who is turning it into
something sharp it's not that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] music in the background a
boring [ __ ] to make it more interesting
listen to that [ __ ] it's like it's like
it's like something that would be in
like a 90s movie where a guy was picking
a safe it's always that [ __ ] music
that they do with boring ass [ __ ] I hate
that I I don't like that I used to not I
made a movie when I was I directed I
wrote and directed a movie it's called
almost when I was 23 years old nobody
knows about that and it's a [ __ ]
straight-up drama dude because your boy
Sirius is [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm services I'll
get out okay
I made it and it [ __ ] went to one
Film Festival and as good as [ __ ]
alright you can't find it anywhere and
that's fine it wasn't even about showing
people to me it was about making it and
the process I loved it alright anyway I
put no music in the movie because I'm so
sick it's so annoying when people you
ever watch Grey's Anatomy and it's like
what are we gonna do belong tacked on
panko gangbang don't think comp link Oh
pink blue dampen the temp temp a temp a
temp mmm popping we got
pom pom pom pom oh oh we got a Code Red
limp pom pom oh but it's okay oh here
comes his wife oh she's frumpy mom give
me back my husband rob a bank all that
[ __ ]
just make it the show man although the
music in that show that outsider is
[ __ ] tripping it's so good anyway
here we go and this is a character who
is turning it into something sharp
snowflake is the person has the more
offensive power and safe spaces god
that's so [ __ ] out of the book it's
offensive it's a more offensive power
just using all these bud buzzwords as
the more defensive the idea was that
they would mirror each other and
complement each other snowflake and
safeSpace are it's just wonderful it's
so wonderful and I don't say wonderful
but it's so [ __ ] wonderful that they
thought this was a good idea that this
is where we're at in 2020 that they
thought that this was a good idea to do
this to white guys and the biggest
[ __ ] company in the world and then
also listen
sweets here waiting for this this is a
parody it has to be there's no way this
is this is something that would be on
[ __ ]
SNL like they would come to save the day
they'd be like here comes safe space and
they're like no but really help me I'm
dying and he's like well I just want to
make sure you're not offended somebody
roat's Robert writes are they still in
denial that the people they are trying
to pander to don't buy comics and then
someone writes back to them just because
they won't talk to your sweaty-ass at
the comic store doesn't mean they're not
buying bobert that's funny actually oh
this is hilarious some guy wrote safe
spaces arch-nemesis will be a villain
called reality wow that's funny good job
moon Bob
good job moon Bob six yeah but to it
like just just chill when you become a
big company see it's funny to like I'm
not I'm not a big big celebrity you know
but I have a lot of followers and [ __ ]
and like when I tweet something that
goes nuts and that gets viral I I get it
like I get more hate and that's just
because more people are under the
umbrella of seeing the [ __ ]
and so you're just not gonna please
everyone like dude did you see that
[ __ ] video Madonna did um where she
was singing how she wanted fried fish to
one of her old songs like this is
something that Madonna if she did it
back in the 80s when there was no
internet nobody would have seen it and
people would have thought what the [ __ ]
on their own and then forgot about it
but now it lives on the internet and
people can hate Madonna now I said once
in my APIs in one of my episodes like
Harrison Ford people [ __ ] there are
people who hate Harrison Ford and you're
like what remember him in the 80s you if
you saw somebody in the 80s or 90s they
were just the [ __ ] period no matter who
it was even even people who hated you
would come up to me like oh my god can I
have an autograph because they never saw
a celebrity they would play they were
big [ __ ] asses when they'd see when
they'd see you and now they're on the
internet behind and by the way that the
couch people are gonna save the world
during this pandemic but they're
chilling and they're watching Madonna
and they're like [ __ ] dis look at this
idiot so had a touch that's the same
[ __ ] that in the 80s would have
walked
to her and ask for a [ __ ] autograph
she did this though come go first of all
she's singing into her hairbrush which
is like only people in movies do that
have you ever actually sang into a
hairbrush if you have then there's
cameras around you and you're Jonathan
Silverman okay
if you have then it's all good I'm not
upset about it but it's nice to meet you
Jonathan Silverman okay
that's all but Madonna writes living in
special times thank God for imagination
and fried fish let's go eat some fried
fish okay she's also doing her
background vocals okay oh and then
messes it up come on vogue I mean go
like do another take
she sponge so hard and looked like she
was gonna fall down so bad she actually
doubles over like almost falls and
that's when you can see in the mirror
she moves over to the mirror and you can
see the guy holding the [ __ ] light
and it's one of the lights that we use
in this studio and my congratulations
podcast and that's so [ __ ] hilarious
that she has a lighting guy like this
well she's like come on go get some
fried fish what the [ __ ] is a South Park
what's happening what is the point what
do you mean there's no more pasta so
let's go eat some fried fish what does
she mean like because she doesn't have
it because of the [ __ ] up a death
because of the pandemic how do you know
that that's what she means that it's
like that that's so
that's so weird that's so weird huh
you know what it is celebrities now that
they have to be in the and I'm talking
about celebrities and not comedians by
the way
comedians seem to have this sort of well
some comedians are [ __ ] out of touch
but it feels like the safest thing to be
online is a comedian because these
singers and these people who are on
social media these actors who just like
now are like okay let's write production
what do I do I guess I'll just sing
about fried fish in my bathroom get the
lighting guy like it's so weird and also
will lead to something like the [ __ ]
gal gadot thing which is just wow wait
hold on this is the thing hold on let me
go back to the I what did I think I
tweeted it yeah I wrote this [ __ ] maybe
want to go to a crowded gal gadot best
of gal on Twitter we are in this
together we will get through this we
will get through it together yeah that's
the [ __ ] I don't like it's like yeah
except for the people that die gal gadot
just posted a video of her and her other
artists who are also quarantine because
of the cove in nineteen singing imagine
by John Lennon on Instagram or on
Instagram yeah so I tweeted this [ __ ]
maybe want to go to a crowd of dance
club and kiss everyone meaning I want to
get the corona virus but dude look at
this by the way let me just go on record
some of these celebrities I actually I
really liked and not that it matters I'm
a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
but like a lot of these people on on
this I like I like gal gadot I like a
lot of these people James Marsden is a
[ __ ] great guy Sarah Silverman is
[ __ ] hilarious she's the only one who
seems to be on this [ __ ] taking the
piss out of it we love we love we love
Sarah
but um yeah it's just so weird that they
did this and that's fine it's so weird
that they did that did this and it's
fine that it's so weird that they did
this but guys you know people are
facedown in [ __ ] ventilators and gal
gadot's like I got it I I got it what
happened your cousin died and your
family is that a work now because of
this pandemic
sit down I got this
let me call nine billion airs do we have
a song for you hey guys I got it chill
get Ashley Benson on the phone you know
what I mean I love Ashley Benson by the
way but it's still funny and it's okay
and it's weird that they did it okay
look at this John Lennon dude you know
John Lennon is obviously he's been he's
dead but he's still one like this Oh
[Music]
imagine all the people who's that guy
dude why are they doing why are they
doing why are they doing this it's weird
to be that like dude people are [ __ ]
dying and out of work and being poor and
they're gonna be on the streets because
of this and they're just in their
mansions singing another song and also
singing badly how could you I don't
that's the whole thing this goes back to
my [ __ ] an away earlier episode I
don't know what episode is on but dude
if you're not a singer don't stare into
the camera and sing for real and posted
on Instagram
you look like a [ __ ] [ __ ] you look
like a [ __ ] [ __ ] these it's like
you're just agreeing you know what you
are you're an Instagram thought that's
what you are I don't care who you are in
this [ __ ]
who are some of these people I mean some
of the people are actual singers I guess
and they sound like this guy that sounds
good I don't I'm an idiot at least this
guy didn't even try that guy from
[ __ ] narcosis and Game of Thrones got
a handsome [ __ ] huh why is he
wearing what Luke Perry would have worn
in 90210 imagine no posessions [ __ ] I
wish they asked me to do it would have
been so cool to be on the [ __ ]
in-crowd not even joking I probably
would have [ __ ] done it that's how
dumb I am I don't like I it probably
also sounded like a good idea in there
now I wouldn't have I [ __ ] would have
done it I would have been so bummed to
cut it over been like gal gadot got in
touch with me through my manager and she
wants me to do that was a mid-sentence
yeah [ __ ] yeah dude
anyway um how come I'm in a [ __ ]
group text with Nick Swardson and when
you're coming to Joe Rogan they talk
about the corona virus we talk about the
corona virus so much and I sent them a
picture of my kid and they didn't
respond to it yes it's all good I guess
we're just talking about serious stuff
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's not a big deal it's fine
but at least say he looks [ __ ] guilty
[Music]
anyway I can't believe this [ __ ] about
about that they did that I just
celebrities left to their own devices
without PR like they don't they can't be
with their PR people they be oh man I
can't imagine trying to call but that's
the thing that'll end up like gal gadot
will get that'll be a positive from gal
gadot in like two years I'd be like
remember when you did that if you're
like I know it was not so maybe the best
idea but we did it you know and it was a
bad idea but there whatever I like music
so and we'll be like haha because she's
so [ __ ] beautiful and a good actress
she really is I think she's great oh you
know what it should have been dude
imagine all the people and then imagine
all the people jeremy renner
[ __ ] yeah dude jeremy renner make one by
yourself I'm gonna do one by myself
imagine oh well how's it start living
out of poverty whoo-hoo you can imagine
all the people on the street and without
any possessions you can imagine them
when they're not cold or hot imagine
that they were all the regular 72 degree
temperature
nobody is uncomfortable and all of them
have stuff to eat and no kids are dying
or adults are dying and most importantly
nobody is dying dude John Travolta
what's his [ __ ] name John Lennon is
in his grave sandy yes right now John
Travolta what the [ __ ] I have a brain
tumor
[ __ ] if I do whatever bro
it's about busting and coming in second
and [ __ ] and drinking coffee hey mom
I'm saving the world I'm on the couch
it's all good do you have any desert in
[Laughter]
MA if you go are you still here [ __ ] my
phone's too far away I think she already
left
[Music]
Funyuns can't get Desert Inn I have you
gone up off the couch I got a rash need
to put a healthy amount of death been on
my ass it's red Polly imagine owl dude I
like the guy who goes I forget who does
it but like I like the geckos imagine
owls or paper I'll try to put a [ __ ]
rock element into it do it I'm rock and
roll
I'm rock and roll did you guys know that
rapper [ __ ] age
in his face that's hilarious what if you
put Ajax in his face face has started to
burn his eyes and I just called
do-do-do-do-do chill chill
I got it imagine all the people standing
by a train Oh whoever it goes I know
zero of those words except for the word
imagine and it's all good one fire said
he was gonna text me when did you when
did you [ __ ] ads any oh he did
already [ __ ] three minutes ago
cool whoops and he did yes but he's
texting minute X chain and I personally
let's do the [ __ ] second ads [ __ ]
I got more stuff to talk about after
that where is it dude we're flying by
the seat of our pants man I'm hot as
[ __ ] dude I'm dripping and I'm doing it
for you and I'm doing it for bags I do
this episode for you and bags period
liquid IV believe it or not a lot of
people end up more dehydrated in winter
months did you know that it's crazy cold
weather makes dehydration harder to spot
so you're less likely to keep refilling
your water bottles water bottles for
water bottles and if you're traveling
dehydration makes jetlag and headaches
even worse well thankfully there's
liquid IV the fastest most efficient way
to stay hydrated
what makes liquid IV so effective well
that's a question I had a little while
ago till I learned about it it's
cellular transport technology ctt the
optimal ratio of glucose sodium and
potassium delivers water and nutrients
into the bloodstream bloodstream now I
know you all know that but I'm just
reiterating it's a perfect balance to
help you hydrate quickly and more
effectively than water alone this this
is nothing
mmm liquid IV one stick of liquid IV in
16 ounces of water can give as much
hydration as two or three bottles of
plain water liquid IV can provide the
same hydration as drinking two to three
bottles of water what the heck that's
crazy it feels tough workouts it
contains five essential vitamins
healthier than traditional sugary sports
drinks don't drink that stuff it's trash
that sports drinks this is the best no
heart of artificial flavors and it's
anyway it's great get 25% off when you
go to liquid IV calm and use code
Congrats at checkout that's 25% off
anything you order on liquid IVs website
just go to liquid ID comm and enter
promo code Congrats to save 25% and get
better hydration that's liquid IV com
promo code Congrats
don't wait start properly hydrating
today it's important babies better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or maybe it's preventing you
from achieving your goals
I used to have that I would get not so
much stressed but anxiety I'd have
trouble sleeping you know my legs would
bunch up as I was going to bed and I
wouldn't be able to fall asleep but this
is something I'd like to talk to you
about that really helps with all that
better help better help will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating in under 24 hours
it's not a crisis line it's not a
self-help it's professional counseling
done securely online there is a broad
range of expertise in better health
better helps counselor network which may
not be locally available in many areas
and especially now it's hard because
it's hard to get out there because
you're indoors because of this pandemic
the service is available for clients
worldwide you can log in your account
anytime and send a message to your
counselor you'll get timely and
thoughtful responses plus you can
schedule a weekly video or phone session
so you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room it's really
cool man it's sometimes you feel lonely
or upset or anxious out there and it's
good to talk to somebody and better help
really can help better help is committed
to facilitating great therapeutic
matches so they make it easy and free to
change counselors if needed it's more
affordable than traditional offline
counseling obviously and financial aid
is even available
visit better help.com / congrats and
join the over 500,000 people taking
charge of their mental health with the
help of an experienced professional
congratulations listeners get 10% off
your first month better help calm /
Congrats
and that great that's great so anyway
yeah boy do I have an announcement
coming up for you in about a month it's
gonna be so awesome it's gonna break the
Internet
can't wait I'm joining forces with
someone that's all I'm gonna say but
it's so cool and I know you're barely
listening to me at this point because
it's after that hats but dude it's
actually so friggin cool where's my
timer I don't know I had a timer and now
I don't know where it is and that's fine
but I don't know how long I've been
going and that's fine about an hour I
think it's been about an hour how long
has it been I'm gonna ask one fire on
text how long has it been how long have
I
hmm been going this is why you turn in
tune into these shits because I don't
cut the [ __ ] out I don't edit stuff I
just ask how long I've been going and
you guys are with me during that time
now do I look the same color as my gray
sweater yes do I need a tan yes am I
gonna get one probably not can I usually
just go outside yes will I know but will
it still be fine
yes my skin won't look like leather when
I'm later on in life it's all good my
babies there's one more thing that I
want to maybe talk about before I even
go into this this is the best the the
the spring breakers Florida spring
breakers dr. dena Grace and tweeted if I
get well she was just tweeting about
this basically letting people know and i
retweeted it but these kids on spring
break this was like days after they told
people that it was a bad bad thing these
[ __ ] idiots do it I get Colonna I get
Corona at the end of the day I'm not
gonna want to stop me from partying you
know
we can wait for Miami Spring Break for a
while but I mean dude okay fine
but also this isn't about you and I
don't expect you to know that but I'm
just telling you you're gonna spread it
and people are gonna die I'm not done
with that sentence you [ __ ] idiot
okay now I am also the guy who's saying
it is so the guy who would be saying it
I can't believe it
it's so crazy two three months Awards
are you having a good time
whatever happens happens people die
people die look at this girl this idiot
I think they're blowing it way out of
proportion I think it's doing way too
much on us bad we need a refund
this virus ain't that serious serious
it's more serious things out there like
hunger it's more serious things out
there that's the best one time I was on
the road with my friend Jason Collings
and we asked a security guard where
there's a Starbucks because the
Starbucks we were close to his closed
and I said and we said hey you know
where there's Starbucks and he said it's
another Starbucks down the block and we
never stopped saying it it's another
Starbucks Starbucks Starbucks
it's another Starbucks a few blocks down
it's another Starbucks dude what's wrong
with theirs even the [ __ ] subtitles
on this fixed it they wrote there's more
serious things out there and he wrote
it's more serious things out there I
think that serious is serious more
serious things out there like hunger and
poverty we need to address that
yeah I mean I love the guy in the back
yes sir the cronies dude 21 this year
some you know parties how does she sound
like that that's the most annoying voice
in the [ __ ] world dude imagine dating
that girl I don't know I just feel like
if we watch the last if we watch it you
know now if we start watching it now I'd
rather just wait till it's all done and
then we can stream it every episode
after another this way you don't have to
wait every Sunday to watch it that's
some [ __ ] she'd say why can't we just
wait until Game of Thrones is over
completely and then we can just stream
it all together this way we can watch it
whenever we want to and we don't have to
wait every Sunday how did she make every
word sound the same she's basically the
[ __ ] she making every word rhyme
she's like I mean she's like the female
Eminem this girl this girl missed her
calling dude she should rhyme orange
with door hinge we need to go home but
like we're here just turn honey on this
year and then I got a part
every [ __ ] syllable is the same I and
I'm at iiiii annoyed I'm out of my
i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i-i
that's Kings this is King speeches
daughter
dude this is King speeches daughter god
I'm the biggest [ __ ] idiot on the
earth I can't believe you listen to this
[ __ ] podcast it's so [ __ ] stupid
and we [ __ ] goin dude and we won't
stop I got a little tousled hair that
went in front of my [ __ ] face when I
said that and that's so goddamn sexy man
imagine me on top of you and we're
[ __ ] doing it and you could be male or
female this isn't about [ __ ] gay or
straight I don't give a [ __ ]
fantasize about me right now me on top
of you and it's sweaty and it feels real
good and I'm doing slow swoop down moves
dude I don't do [ __ ] bang at a bang
at a bang it I don't [ __ ] like that in
fact I never [ __ ] I only made love
even with hookers never had one but I'm
just saying if I were going to I would
make love I don't care if I have to pay
you afterwards I don't [ __ ] it's you
know what it is dude it's so [ __ ] it
really is okay so imagine me on top my
shoulders did they shoot Brokeback
Mountain on the back of them maybe it
was a long time ago when my shoulders
weren't as beefy but you guarantee if
they made a sequel they would be back
there right now and imagine me on top
you in sweats dripping and it's all good
and whether you're a male or female
let's say you're a male I don't give a
[ __ ] we're still you know I never
understood really how gay guys could do
it not doggy style cuz it's kind of
weird to me if the guys on his back and
the other guys on top of them and then
that guy's kind of dick is just like
flopping around or whatever I don't know
does he jerk off or do you do it hey
dude I don't know but if you want real
[ __ ] listen to NPR but if you want the
really real [ __ ] stay tuned to my babies
because this is the [ __ ] that NPR should
be talking about when gay guys [ __ ] not
doggy style is the guy on the bottoms
dick flopping around
that's all I want to know okay but my
point is I lost my train of thought I
lost my train of thought I lost my train
of thought oh yeah got it
I'm sexy because if I'm on top of you
and if you're a [ __ ] dude let's say
your name's Hank or whatever and I'm
gonna top of you and your dicks flopping
around and I'm doing those slow
controlled swoop down movements right I
don't want to say I'm known for but I I
know I do them and then all of a sudden
my [ __ ] wisp of hair goes in front of
my eyes that's it do it it's important
everywhere everybody is supporting
everywhere even people that aren't
involved in the sex come in and then lo
and they starts flirting and slipping
and falling and hurting their tail bones
because that's what happens doe dude
girls and guys and then jeremy renner
comes in and goes oh my god sensational
sensational I'm a deejay dude well these
DJ's are doing live streams on Instagram
because of the pandemic do it not fun
the whole [ __ ] dude it's not fun
there if it's at least if you're one of
those guys that [ __ ] likes to UNT's
it out at least [ __ ] do it there and
take Molli and be like I love when the B
I could feel the beat I could feel the
beat dude imagine being at home watching
[ __ ] it Mighty Mouse or whatever the
[ __ ] his name is on the [ __ ] does he
still wear his thing Minnie Mouse the
[ __ ] is that guy's name Mouse DJ head
dad Baus deadmau5 hahaha dude deadmau5
go buy like we're here I just turned 21
this year so I'm you know party so it's
kind of disappointing but we're just
making the most of it we met these other
people and our lid
air B&B spots ah we're just hanging out
with them worst story ever dude
ding-ding-ding-ding-ding ah as a [ __ ]
grenade dude that [ __ ] [ __ ] right
there come on
what I just turned 21 this year so I'm
here to party so it's kind of
disappointing but we're just making the
most of it we met these other people in
our little Airbnb spot so we're just
hanging out with them and trying to get
drunk before everything closet ding ding
ding ding ding ding ding that's the
[ __ ] a grenade did you knew I was
gonna do an F grenade you knew it was
only a matter of time dude
anyway um how does she [ __ ] ripe
she's the female M&M dude yeah I mean
it's a long time ago it was funnier I
mean we playing this a long time it was
kind of up in the air if we were still
going but like what still I just turned
21 this year and a Barney it's gonna
disappoint but we're just making most of
it people in a little ambient be spot so
we're just hanging out with them trying
to get drunk before everything class
[Laughter]
[ __ ] dude I'm dripping so [ __ ] hard
man
it is so sweaty and hot in here what's
the deal with this [ __ ] dude I think I
did more than [ __ ] enough probably
I'm gonna finish up here that's it dude
I had a good time with you guys
[Music]
I just can't just stay inside dude just
stay inside for at least a few weeks let
me
this thing here I need my [ __ ] email
up god damn it I need oh there's my
timer
I need my email up Gmail uh that's fine
is what it is uh oh did he [ __ ] email
it to me dude okay that's it that's it
guys thanks for listening you know uh so
not important the last [ __ ] 20
seconds of what I just did but you guys
stuck with me cuz you guys are the [ __ ]
and you guys are the real babies and I
love you guys I probably but don't love
some of you but some of you I might love
I don't I mean honestly I don't know
many of you I don't know I don't know
about few of you but uh text me at eight
one eight two three nine seventy eighty
seven support the show by by oh I think
it's all done did you get those D'Elia
Callen crewnecks those are all done but
the life rips things are back in stock
you can go check those out and get them
and subscribe to the YouTube channel
that really helps but you guys are great
thank you very much I moved a lot of
these dates like Rohnert Park move to I
think I don't know the summer and West
Palm Beach move to the summer so go
check it out August are the new Las
Vegas dates but you guys are great sorry
everything's been canceled or just
postponed but
everything and my babies we did it
that's our second [ __ ] quarantined
episode guys right baby
[Music]